so my name's robert i am the chief
product officer of hyperquery uh where
we're making a doc workspace for
analytics uh and the original title of
this talk was called dashboards
dashboards everywhere and it was a super
super cerebral thing where i
i talked about how analytics
collaboration is really broken
and i went through this sort of
highfalutin logical argument about why
it should get fixed and i used all sorts
of things like um you know i use
flowcharts and i'm you know i'm skipping
it right because it's the last day uh i
used pie charts i used all sorts of like
jargon from the modern data stack and
like data over the last
uh year
so you know just believe that i know
what these are
no one maybe really knows what they are
um and i realized like on my third quote
from a philosopher that there is no way
that anyone has enough
coffee and or alcohol in their veins
right now to listen to me give that talk
so i threw it away and i started over um
this is called put it in a dock
so i'll be very very transparent with
you um i'm gonna basically i'm you know
i'm a vendor right like i work for
hypercore i'm a co-founder there i'm
gonna sell you our products and our
product is a doc workspace
and i'm going to argue that all the
problems that you have in analytics are
going to get fixed if you start putting
your work in in a dock so you know i'll
have watch this hold on
yeah so i'll have nice animations so you
can all
remember what's happening and follow
along um
and i said i wouldn't pontificate but
i'll i'll give me like one minute so
just pay attention for one minute and
then it'll be back to like memes and
spinning and things like that so um
let me talk about what the problem is so
i'm talking about sql-based analytics
here i think there's this like workflow
around doing sql-based work right like
data engineers data scientists data
analysts we all get like questions
about data we're like the gatekeepers of
data
and we have great tools
to like
figure out what our data is i mean
there's select star there's data
discovery tools there's all sorts of
great infrastructural tools there's
dashboards there's sql ids like finding
data and writing sql is like our bread
and butter right it's completely fine
the problem with
these tools is that they don't address
the hardest problem in analytics which
is that other people are
really freaking hard
so working with other people ends up
being like this huge part of the
workflow right um so
i made a quick diagram this is the only
diagram i promise that i'll throw at you
around here
is where you actually do the work but
there's all this work around it right
like you have to decide like what's the
problem that you're answering like you
have to actually figure out why you're
doing the work to begin with
um then you have to start the work and
that's you know it sounds stupid but you
have to like find what other people have
done you have to like ask your
co-workers like what the hell is this
table
and then later you have to revisit the
work when your pm inevitably asks you
like hey
uh can you refresh this analysis and you
know we've all sort of been there i'm
sure we all have like battle stories and
battle scars about that
and all of these things in my opinion
are just like really broken like no one
has figured out how to how to make these
better um
short answer like use our use our
product right
but you know i'll talk about this uh one
by one
i think with framing that oh this is a
this is a oh this is so cool okay sweet
um so with framing the problem
uh so i'm a little bit tired too it's
like the last day i've been talking to
people for the last like two two days um
so framing the problem like we often get
this wrong right like uh we often don't
answer the right questions um so
i think a few of you know already but i
used to be at airbnb i was a data
scientist there
um and i had this experience where i i
got pulled into a sort of like startup
within a a
startup team where i
uh reported directly to i was on a team
that reported directly to brian chesky
the ceo which was
fun
but uh
naturally like he he would ask us tons
of questions right it would be stuff
like hey how many olympians do we have
hey like of those olympians how many of
them do you think will be hosts but it
was like never the right question like
he was always like asking these
questions that were like
things that he wanted to know but not
but really like he had he and a lot lots
of other stakeholders had really gotten
used to this process of asking analysts
what data they wanted rather than asking
them to
uh
about the actual question that they want
answered so they would always ask for
data rather than asking questions
um and i realized like
this was just a problem of alignment
right
um
we never aligned on what the actual
actual business objective was i was just
sort of like a sql monkey in this
process and so at the end of the day
we wasted a lot of cycles going back and
forth and back and forth just trying to
answer
different iterations on questions that
actually didn't matter so
that's part of it next part of it
starting the work
um past work is just not discoverable
you know i had this like
workflow that i was really proud of
proud of for all my ad hoc work so all
my sql work where i like shoved
everything into my local local drive i
backed it up with git um but i could
never find anything like it was tough to
just remember like what tables i'd used
to have to remember like why i'd written
these queries in the first place
um let alone find anyone else's work
right like nobody else would put their
stuff in a central place like my stuff
was on my drive but no one else's stuff
was on my drive right
did that sentence make sense i think so
i should have had some coffee okay
and then finally passwork is not
reproducible so at the end of the day
three months later your pm comes back to
you and says
like hey uh please do this again and
you have no idea unless you're like
really really meticulous but i don't
think most people are there's no way
that you're going to be able to like
replicate the results in exactly the
same way right
and so the answer is and now it's going
to get really dumb just
put your work in a doc workspace um so
what do we mean by this as i said like i
want to make it really really clear that
i am a vendor
uh the bias here should be very obvious
we are building a dock workspace so you
know notion can work something like that
but we're building a dock workspace
where you can
write sql uh so that way you can write
your sql do your work and then
put it here share it find it later
um
yeah
okay let me move on
uh so here you go spinning put it in a
dock
first point
okay so that's the end of the talk
i'm going to now just walk you through a
bunch of scenarios so you can all sort
of
hear this point over and over again
and i want this to be like somewhat
somewhat interactive so
uh scenario number one imagine you are
working at airbnb
um may or may not be a real scenario
covet has just started
and yeah people are holding hoarding
toilet paper it's like it's like the end
of the world airbnb's numbers have
dropped to like zero and like all your
stakeholders are now coming to you and
they're like hey hey um
in what markets should we
like
acquire targeted supply to like fix the
business right
um
so what do you do
i'll give you guys three choices one is
you make a dashboard
two is you pull some data real quick and
three is you align on the problem uh in
a doc workspace which you know i'm
leading the question a little bit right
so let's say dashboards how about
dashboards
okay okay a couple of you could
uh who would start pulling some data
okay awesome good honest people i like
that
and then who would uh align on the work
beforehand
awesome uh you all are either very very
uh disillusioned about your workflow or
very very meticulous uh but i really
think you're just lying so
um but and i just want to make myself
feel better because i made a dashboard
which you know you over there like thank
you for giving me some make me making me
feel a little bit better
about myself
um and you know this was like a this was
a panicked period right like we didn't
really know how to answer this question
we didn't really know what we wanted to
do
and so like all the data science leaders
were like let's just make a dashboard so
people can just figure out like
at least
get some access to data start like
juggling the juices a little bit and and
find an answer um the issue was that the
dashboard was never used right and this
is like the title of the talk like it's
dashboard dashboards everywhere and we
realize that like nobody nobody who's
making a decision ever wants to use a
dashboard
to make the decision they want like your
interpretation on the data right this is
like why we're we're we have jobs as
like analytics or uh data people right
um
so lesson there is you should put your
work in a doc and that's what we did at
the end of the day like we we ended up
yeah using the dashboard as a great tool
to like explore the data but at the end
of the day we created a doc
we explained our thesis we talked about
our argument and then everybody had a
really great time like making the
decision to save the business
um yeah
so
second scenario um i'm gonna just keep
talking about airbnb uh second scenario
airbnb is looking for new business
opportunities
um you get an ad hoc request which is
how many tree houses do we have uh and
i'm not gonna pull you guys again i
think you know you guys uh probably get
it um what i did was i pulled some data
real quick right which is like like the
right answer this is like what everybody
does right
um i know what the table is that has
tree houses in it so i i just
dumpster dived and i like ran after ran
after that table um and the issue was
that like this came with like 50 other
questions right after which were like
hey so
that seems low can you make that number
higher
which is a ridiculous thing right like
you can't just make the number higher
but like under that was an actual
business question which was like
hey
how do we broadly define tree houses so
that this is a viable business
opportunity and then that's like a
completely different question
we answered that at the end but we had a
lot of wasted cycles trying to like get
people to
to actually like tell us that this was
the question they wanted answered
um
and at the end of the day
what you should do is
put it in a dock right so at the end of
the day like this is the kind of thing
that you put in a sql id tab right
but then
we would have wasted a lot less cycles
if we had just put it in a dock
um so
what am i at
oh five minutes okay cool i'll leave
some time for questions but um
third one i used to work at wayfair i
was more on the ml side of things so um
i had an algorithm that i shipped uh and
then month to month month over month uh
we found that that algorithm spent oh my
god this was a terrible memory it was
like my first job out of out of grad
school right and
um
we found like one month model did very
very well the second month the model did
very very badly and we spent like 10
times more than
we had the previous month which is like
millions of dollars right so i felt
pretty bad about this
um
and
i got an ad hoc request which was hey
why is our ad cost so high right which
you might expect like i mean everyone i
think i got this like 20 times right
from from everyone from like the
business stakeholder up to like a vp and
so what i did was i you know you i felt
the pressure i was like i need to answer
this really quick or we're going to burn
all of our cash
and
you know it was fine it was the right
right question to answer but the issue
was that one month later i got this
question again and you know i not having
ever worked in data job before i didn't
save my work which meant that i had to
redo the old work which meant that
i couldn't actually reproduce that work
and so i had to do the analysis again
and then walk back my first inference
that i had given to a stakeholder and
this was this was like by far the worst
thing that like had happened to me in
that job it was really really painful to
tell an exec like hey um remember that
result from last month yeah actually
that like wasn't the right story here's
here's the right story um
and again uh i keep pressing the wrong
button
um i while i answer the right question
uh it wasn't discoverable by myself it
wasn't reproducible
uh and putting this in a dock or some
sort of workspace where this is a little
bit more conducive would have saved a
ton of work so again put it in a dock
yeah
um okay final one this one will be
really quick
okay this is actually while i've been at
hyperquery or
our corporation um customers are
complaining about our app performance
this is we solved this problem so like
don't think about this as like our app
doesn't work
uh but i got an ad hoc request for more
cto how many queries are usually in a
doc um what i did was i did it in a doc
you can explain i mean like you can
expect like what happened was this is
this was great i got the question again
later because our app performance went
down again we had to look at this again
and everything was peachy like we had a
great dock which was really really quite
simple right like i just have an
objective here i have an answer and then
we can oh by the way this is really
interesting somebody made like 52
queries in a single doc isn't that
ridiculous like i'm getting distracted
but who does that right um if you are
that person i'm really sorry i don't
mean to put you on the spot
uh but anyways um
the point is that the deliverable was
not only high value it was really high
leverage we could use it again and again
we could find it again and again
and so the moral of the story is put it
in a doc
okay
i think i have a demo here but i'll just
leave time for questions
this is our app hyperquery so it's a doc
workspace where you can do all sorts of
wizzy wig stuff and you can also execute
query
queries against your data warehouse
within it
[Applause]